REPORT BEING ON THE GROUND
DURING SEAN'S SHOW, TUCKER?
>> Tucker: GRIFF JENKINS IN
CALIFORNIA.
THANKS, GRIFF.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF TIME,
THE RHETORIC ON ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION ON THE LEFT HAS
BECOME INCREASINGLY BRAZEN
AND THE INTENTIONS OF THOSE
WHO ESPOUSE IT ARE LESS
DISGUISED THAN THEY HAVE
EVER ABOUT BEEN.
BILL CLINTON PLEDGED TO
DEPORT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS HE
GOT ELECTED.
IN THE 90'S HILLARY
IN THE 90'S TILLARY
IN THE 90'S THELARY
IN THE 90'S THENARY
IN THE 90'S THEN AY
IN THE 90'S THEN AS
PRESIDENT OBAMA CREATED DACA
AND OTHER PROGRAMS TO BLOCK
DEPORTATION FOR CERTAIN
SPHAFERRED ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
GROUPS.
NOW NUT TRUMP PRESIDENCY,
THE MASK IS OFF.
THE LEFT TELLS US THAT NO
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT SHOULD
EVER BE DEPORTED EVEN ONES
THAT CREDIT COMMITTED
CRIMES.
NOT ONLY THAT THEY SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO VOTE.
VARGAS AND JENNIFER PALMIERI
HAVE BOTH HINTED ABOUT THAT
RECENTLY ON THIS SHOW.
WATCH.
>> I DO BELIEVE THAT WE
SHOULD HAVE UNIVERSAL VOTING
FOR EVERYONE TO ENSURE THAT
EVERYONE HAS.
>> Tucker: FROM CITIZENS OF
OTHER COUNTRIES.
>> NO TAXATION WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION.
THAT'S A FUNDAMENTAL.
>> Tucker: ANYONE IN THE
WORLD WHO COMES TO THE
UNITED STATES AND BUYING A
DECK OF MARLBOROS AND PAYS A
SALES TAX THAT PERSON COULD
VOTE.
>> IF THAT PERSON COMES TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE COUNTRY
LET HIM HAVE A SAY IN HIS
GOVERNMENT.
>> Tucker: LET FOREIGNERS
VOTE.
I HOPE THE DEMOCRATS RUN ON
THAT.
I THINK IT WILL BE A FUN
ELECTION.
>> Tucker: DETAILS MATTER
YOU SAID SHOULD NEVER VOTE.
I VOTE YOUR PARTY WILL
OVERTAKE YOU ON THAT
QUESTION.
WE WILL SEE.
>> MAYBE IF CONGRESS NEVER
DOES ANYTHING TO ADDRESS
IMMIGRATION.
>> Tucker: WOULD ANY OTHER
COUNTRY TOLERATE THAT?
WOULD THAT IDEA BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY ANY PLACE BUT IN
THE UNITED STATES?
MEXICO DOESN'T TAKE IT
SERIOUSLY.
IN FACT THE MENTION CAN
CONSTITUTION EXPLICITLY SAYS
QUOTE FOREIGNERS SHALL NOT
IN ANY WAY INVOLVE
THEMSELVES IN THE POLITICAL
MATTERS OF THE COUNTRY.
NOBODY IS ATTACKING MEXICO
FOR THAT MEXICO IS NOT BEING
DENOUNCED AS RACIST FOR
THOUGHT LETTING SALVADOR
RANS
SANS
SALS
SAL SALVADORRANS VOTE.
ONLY IN THE UNITED STATES IS
THERE A DIFFERENT STANDARD
AND BECAUSE THE LEFT SEES
THE NEW STANDARD AS A WAY TO
OBTAIN POWER AND HOLD IT
FOREVER.
CATHY ROUX IS PUBLISHER OF
CATALINA MAGAZINE AND UNLIKE
MANY ON THE LEFT HONEST
ABOUT WHAT SHE THINKS.
SHE JOINS US TONIGHT.
YOU THINK PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
CITIZENS OF THE UNITED
STATES OUGHT TO BE ALLOWED
TO VOTE IN FEDERAL
ELECTIONS, CORRECT?
>> I FEEL THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE CONTRIBUTING AND ARE
HUMANS AND ARE IN OUR
SOCIETY AND CONTRIBUTING TO
OUR SOCIETY SHOULD HAVE A
OUR DEMOCRACY, YES.
>> Tucker: HOW WOULD WE
MEASURE THAT?
WOULD WE SAY THAT EVERYONE
WHO IS MAKING A NET
CONTRIBUTION, PAYING MORE IN
TAXES THAN THEY'RE GETTING
IN SERVICES, FOR EXAMPLE,
THOSE PEOPLE CAN VOTE OR
PEOPLE OWN PROPERTY CAN
VOTE?
>> WE HAVE SO MANY PEOPLE
THAT ARE LIVING IN THIS
COUNTRY, WE HAVE ABOUT
11 MILLION, 12 MILLION
PEOPLE LIVING IN THIS
COUNTRY, CONTRIBUTING TO OUR
SOCIETY, PAYING THEIR TAXES
AS PREVIOUS GUEST HAD SAID.
TAXATION WITHOUT
REPRESENTATION.
THERE ARE SO MANY PEOPLE
LIVING HERE BUT DON'T HAVE A
VOICE.
THEY DO HAVE A VOICE, THEY
DO FEEL MORE EMPOWERED AND
ARE PART OF OUR SEWS THEY
DEFINITELY WOULD BE
EMPOWERED BY VOTING.
COULD I BE ON VACATION HERE
FROM ANOTHER COUNTRY AND
STAY FOR A WHILE, CONTRIBUTE
GREATLY, HOW LONG WE HAVE TO
STAY IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
VOTE?
>> WELL, I MEAN, I THINK IT
GOES STATE BY STATE.
I THINK MARYLAND RIGHT NOW
HAS A FEW CITIES THAT
ALLOWED UNDOCUMENTED PEOPLE
TO VOTE.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> I WOULD WONDER HOW
MARYLAND IS DOING IT.
THAT'S NOT CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S MARYLAND.
I WOULD SAY WE OUGHT TO
ADOPT WHAT MARYLAND IS DOING
IN OTHER STATES.
>> Tucker: IF FOREIGNERS
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO VOTE IN
OUR ELECTIONS, WHY SHOULDN'T
RESIDENTS OF MISSISSIPPI BE
ALLOWED TO VOTE IN
CALIFORNIA ELECTION?
>> EXACTLY WE SHOULD.
THE UNITED STATES IS THE
UNITED STATES.
SO, YEAH, IF I'M A FLORIDIAN
AND I'M VISITING NEW YORK
SO, WHY CAN'T I VOTE IN NEW
YORK?
ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
VOTE WHEREVER WE HAPPEN TO
BE, YEAH.
>> Tucker: SHOULD WOULD HE
BE ABLE TO VOTE IN MEXICO?
>> WELL, IF WE ARE
CONTRIBUTING TO THEIR
SOCIETY AND LIVING THERE FOR
YEARS AND PERHAPS IF THERE
SALAH THAT ALLOWS US TO,
ABSOLUTELY.
BUT THE AMERICAN WAY WAS
ESTABLISHED WITH PEOPLE
VOTING IN THE 1700S THAT
WERE UNDOCUMENTED SO WE
ACTUALLY WERE CREATED AS A
NATION OF PEOPLE THAT WERE
UNDOCUMENTED AND VOTING.
>> Tucker: YEAH, A NATION OF
ILLEGALS FOR SURE.
>> UNDOCUMENTED.
>> Tucker: YEAH ILLEGAL
UNDOCUMENTED THAT'S A HYBRID
OF THE TWO.
THEIR CONSTITUTION SAYS THAT
FOREIGNERS ARE NOT ALLOWED
TO PARTICIPATE IN ANY WAY IN
THEIR POLITICS.
ISN'T THAT RACIST?
>> WELL, I MEAN, BUT,
AMERICA IS NOT RACIST.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES AMERICA SO
BEAUTIFUL.
AMERICA IS A MELTING POT SO
THAT WOULD ONLY MAKE SENSE
THAT WE WOULD ALLOW PEOPLE
WHO ARE CONTRIBUTING TO OUR
SOCIETY.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> TO VOTE.
SO THAT WOULD MAKE SENSE.
WE ARE A WONDERFUL NATION.
>> Tucker: WHY ARE WE UPSET
ABOUT RUSSIAN INFLUENCE IN
OUR ELECTIONS THEN?
ISN'T THAT KIND OF WHAT WE
WANT?
I MEAN, THERE ARE A LOT OF
RUSSIANS LIVING HERE.
RUSSIAN DIPLOMATS LIVING
HERE LONG TERM LIVING HERE
KISLYAK THE LONG TIME
AMBASSADOR HERE.
>> PEOPLE CONTRIBUTING AND